On veut faire un film. Pour ça on a enlevé
François. On lui a pris tout son matos.
Il nous a parlé de caméras,
de réglages, de lumière.
Je sens que ça va mal tourner mais
on n'en a pas encore encore fini.
Le look cinéma, ça on en a besoin.
On va lui faire cracher le morceau.
Mais vous êtes complètement tarés ? Vous avez
pris tout mon matos ? Mais c'est mes outils,
c'est ma vie ! Comment je vais faire moi ?
Ça va, c'est bon, de toute façon, on sait
bien que c'est pas mon métier et vidéaste.
Mais t'es con quoi c'est exactement ce qu'on
essaie de faire. Non mais je veux dire c'est
pas mon vrai métier comme tourneur fraiseur,
pizzaïolo, plaquiste... ostréiculteur... coiffeur
-Bon, on va te le rendre ton matos.
-Vous avez plutôt intérêt
-Tout doux, tout doux, tout doux, de
toute façon on sait quasiment tout.
-On va l'avoir grâce à lui le look cinéma
- Le look cinéma ah ah
-Non mais vous étiez sérieux là ?
-Ouais attend le look cinéma c'est
le truc qu'on voit partout sur internet
-Ah oui ça pour faire cliquer, pour vendre du
rêve... je dis pas que les gens qui en parlent
font de mauvaises images, mais c'est quoi pour
vous déjà le look cinéma
-Bah c'est simple.
-Hyper simple
-Et puis de toute façon, ici
c'est moi qui pose les questions !
-Ouais vous en savais rien en fait quoi.
-Stop François, stop.. trop c'est trop stop.
J'en ai marre de jouer au chat et aux bol de riz.
On va pas se tailler le cul en étoile pour
chier des churros. Alors maintenant tu vas
nous dire exactement tout ce qu'on veut savoir
sur le look cinéma. Même si j'ai déjà une petite
idée de la réponse. Le look cinéma, c'est les
deux bandes noires en haut et en bas de l'écran.
-Le format scope tu veux dire ?
-Oui.. le franc mascotte...
Ces bandes noires qu'on voit sur un film quand
on regarde sur une télévision 16/9 c'est ce qu'on
appelle le CinémaScope. Et il ya plein de formats
différents avec des mesures différentes mais on va
faire simple. Et là où c'est trompeur c'est qu'à
la base il n'y a pas de bandes noires. C'est juste
une image plus large avec un ratio de 2,35 pour
1. D'où ça vient ? Et bien le CinémaScope c'est un
procédé inventé par un français du nom de Henri
Chrétien qui a créé le dispositif de l'optique
anamorphique en prise de vues comme en projection
appelé hypergonar. Ce monsieur est aussi connu
pour l'invention du cinéma en relief tout comme
d'autres technologies liées au cinéma. Et c'est
grâce à ce procédé qu'on appelle l'anamorphose
qu'on obtient le fameux CinémaScope. On va filmer
avec une optique qui déforme l'image pour ensuite
venir recompresser cette image et redonner leur
forme réelle aux choses. Ce qui a pour effet
de réduire la hauteur de l'image et lui donner
ce look très particulier. Le CinémaScope est un
format qui permet de doubler la largeur du format
4/3, c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui les meilleures
caméras pour de l'anamorphique sont celles qui
ont un capteur 4/3. Pour l'anecdote, même si on
continue d'appeler ça du 2,35 dans les faits en
numérique on est passé sur de 2,39 ou même du 2,40
pour 1. En gros, si on rajoute les bandes noires
artificiellement en haut et en bas pour donner
ce book, oui, ça rappelle le CinémaScope,
mais ça n'en est pas. D'autant plus que tous les
films ne sont pas sur en format large comme celui
là. The Lighthouse par exemple est au format
carré, ou plus récemment la version Snyder Cut
de Justice League qui est au format 4/3.
-Donc dans les bandes noires
c'est pas forcément cinéma.
-J'étais sûr pourtant que...
-Tu m'as pris par surprise. Je sais. La caméra et
les objectifs, c'est ça qui fait le look cinéma.
Alors dans le cinéma on voit souvent
effectivement de grosses caméras avec
de gros objectifs qui coûtent à eux seuls le
prix d'un appartement parisien. Ces caméras et
optiques participent à donner UN look, mais
est-ce que tu savais que certaines scènes
de Captain America avaient été tourné avec
un canon 5d mark ii ? Et on en parle de la
Gopro dans le Hobbit ? Et puis au delà de ça
il y a des films entiers qui ont été tournées
avec autre chose que des super caméra dernier
cri. Prend Paranoïa de steven soderbergh : 100%
filmé à l'iPhone. Le projet Blair Witch : avec
une simple caméra DV. Tu sais le caméscope de
papa ? Et récemment Zack Snyder a sorti un court
métrage de malade réalisé en un week-end avec un
iPhone 7. Ça prouve bien qu'un film c'est certes
du matériel, une équipe, des moyens de production
mais ça ne se limite pas à ça.
-Donc bah non toujours pas.
-Ahhh je sais c'est la
couleur, les look up table...
Les LUT.
Alors l'étalonnage, c'est clair que c'est
une étape cruciale dans la conception du
look d'un film. Mais il y a tellement de façons
d'étalonner. On peut avoir un traditionnel "Teal
and Orange" qu'on retrouve dans énormément de
grosses productions, mais il y en a tellement
d'autres. Regarde Matrix et sa teinte verte qui te
montre bien à quel moment les héros sont dans la
matrice. Mad Max Fury Road et ses teintes ocre
qui te donnent l'impression que tu es toi même
dans le désert. Sin City de Robert Rodriguez
et son look BD qu'ils te plonge dans l'univers
d'un comics. 300 et tellement d'autres... Et
aucun de ces films a la même couleur. Mais ça
c'est la finition. Sur les images de ces films
on aurait pu faire n'importe quel traitement
de couleur ou de contraste. C'est un choix
scénaristique autant qu'un choix esthétique.
Et puis les filtres et autres LUT, c'est bien,
ça peut aider. Mais l'étalonnage ça ne se limite
pas à ce genre de choses. C'est bien plus complexe
une LUT, c'est figé alors qu'un film évolue et
surtout et colorisé en fonction de ce que le
réalisateur veut faire passer comme message.
-Bon alors tu attends quoi pour nous le dire.
Si tu continues à vouloir jouer au plus malin
ça va très mal se passer François.
-Ah bah si tu fais péter ça,
tu vas galérer à le faire ton film
-Tu vois il a compris que c'était pas une vraie...
-TAIS-TOI !!! Tais-toi...
-Attends, tu veux faire un film et tu
sais même pas me dire ce que c'est le cinéma ?
- Moi je sais pas ce que c'est le cinéma ?
-Sérieux...
-Oui sérieusement.
-Essaye encore.
-Oui faisons ça.
-Bah fais-le.
-Slooooooooowwwww moooooooootiooooooon...
Bah quoi ? Slow motion les
gars ? Ça c'est cinématique !
Alors d'abord on va définir ce qu'est le slow
motion. Parce que c'est un argument marketing très
important pour les marques de caméras. Le slow
motion c'est en français du ralenti. Au cinéma,
on diffuse généralement en 24 images par seconde
quand on filme à vitesse réelle sans prévoir de
ralentis, on filme donc à la même cadence :
24 images par seconde. Pour faire du ralenti
c'est très simple : on va filmer à une cadence
supérieure. 48, 96 et y a même des caméras qui
filment à plus de 1000 images par seconde. Des
ralentit on en retrouve dans beaucoup de films,
principalement pour des scènes d'action, pour
casser le rythme, détailler un mouvement,
figer le temps et généralement, ajouter une
intensité dramatique. Tu as par exemple la
fameuse scène de Matrix, le "bullet time" qui pour
l'époque était une véritable prouesse technique
puisqu'elle a demandé l'installation de dizaines
d'appareils photo. Mais on va pas se mentir,
les ralentis sur les vidéos que tu peux voir
sur internet, c'est souvent du cache-misère.
Parce que ça a plusieurs avantages. Déjà tu as une
impression de stabilité plus importante ça permet
d'utiliser des plans à main levée que tu n'aurais
pas pu utiliser à vitesse réelle. Ça permet
également de réaliser des mouvements de caméra
stylés assez simplement. Mais neuf fois sur dix,
ces ralentis ne sont pas utilisés dans un but
précis. C'est joli et c'est surtout très pratique.
Je critique pas hein, je le fais aussi mais c'est
pas le ralenti qui va te donner ton look cinéma.
-Bon ça suffit maintenant.
les plans stabilisateur ?
-Non.
-Steady cam ?
-Non plus
-Les filtres de diffusion ?
-Les filtres ND ?
-Aucun des deux.
-Les mouvements de caméra ?
-Non plus.
-La désaturation partielle ?
-Non.
-Leeeees....
-...titres?
-Non.
-Les transitions ?
-Les transitions.
-Transition.
-Les transitions ? Cinéma sérieux ?
Une transition ce n'est pas un effet ou un
plugin. Avant tout les transitions c'est un
peu la ponctuation du cinéma, un moyen de passer
d'un plan un autre. Les plus connus sont le cut,
une transition brute d'un plan à un autre mais qui
peut être pleine de sens comme dans cette scène de
The Haunting of Hill House ou le fondu qui peut
être un fondu au noir ou un fondu enchaîné dans
lequel deux images se chevauchent. Mais l'idée
d'une transition c'est de passer d'une scène à
une autre en guidant le spectateur pour comprendre
l'histoire, la psychologie d'un personnage,
ou tout un tas d'autres choses. Au cinéma, même
dans les transitions, il y a de la narration.
-Ouais et les "smooth zoom" par exemple ? Tout
le monde dit sur youtube que ça fait cinéma.
-T'en as vu beaucoup des
smooth zooms au cinéma toi ?
-...
- Ouais, c'est ce que je pensais.
-Ok...tant pis j'appuie sur le bouton
-Bah non.
-Bah si.
-Si...
-Bah non.
-Bah si.
-Tu déconnes là ?
-Non.
-Si.
-Tu m'avais dit que c'était pas une vraie ?
-Bah si
-François lâche nous un indice là !
Comment on l'a ce p***** de look cinéma ?
Non mais là vous cherchez un truc existe ou
pas. Le look cinéma c'est une hérésie de dire
ça. Y'a pas UN look cinéma. À la limite si
je devais donner ma définition du cinéma ce
serait ça : pour moi, c'est quand tout a un sens
quand tous les éléments, du choix de la caméra,
en passant par l'éclairage, le jeu des acteurs, le
choix des optiques, le décor... quand tout ça est
pensé. C'est quand chacun de ces éléments raconte
quelque chose et nous procure des émotions. Pour
moi c'est ça qui fait le cinéma. Non une
séquence d'illustration en slowmo au milieu
d'un blog ça n'a rien de cinématographique. C'est
pas parce que c'est beau que c'est du cinéma. Et
d'ailleurs ça enlève rien à la qualité de ces
vidéos et au talent de ceux qui les réalisent.
Mais moi, j'aime le cinéma, depuis toujours et
même si la définition peut varier en fonction
de chacun, il y a une chose qu'on peut pas
laisser de côté. Le cinéma ça nous fait rire,
ça nous fait pleurer, ça nous fait peur, ça
nous fait exulter, ou ça nous met en colère.
Le cinéma c'est avant tout des histoires et des
émotions. Et aujourd'hui on a tendance à oublier
avec tout le contenu des réseaux sociaux. On
prend plus le temps de raconter des histoires,
car qu'on soit petit ou grand, s'il ya un
truc que tout le monde aime, c'est qu'on
lui raconte une histoire. Tous les deux vous
voulez faire un film : c'est une super idée
mais est-ce que vous avez un truc à
raconter ou est ce que vous voulez
juste faire un déballage de matos ?
-On a tout faux depuis le début moi
je pensais que tu savais un minimum de quoi tu
parlais. En fait on n'est pas prêts du tout.
-Tu as raison... on a tout faux depuis le début.
On a fait les trucs à l'envers... oui oui la
vidéo c'est peut-être pas notre truc en
fait finalement. On va repartir à zéro et
oublier tout ça désolé. Et puis vous pensiez
quand même pas que j'allais faire péter une..